i've always noticed this about you you
were very upbeat
person and i appreciate that because i
said we we did a tour together we went
to a lot of cities we were in
you know close quarters a lot and you're
always
you seem optimistic you're you've got a
good life energy how do you maintain
that
is it tough to do like right now uh
sometimes yeah
sometimes it is tough to do when you you
can just start getting
down on i mean all of us if you look for
carls you'll find them you know you can
say what's going wrong and see and it's
all around you but
um i just think like this time period is
what i'm built for it's because if it's
easy to be optimistic when things are
going well
just like you know when comedy and
everything was flourishing everybody was
here in town and then
as a china trouble everybody wants to
leave but like
i'm just i'm here i have nowhere else to
go i want to do this and
whether it's as you know i want it to be
or something different i'll do my part
to make it
better and be a positive actually that's
my job is your i have found like my kids
my kids are my daughter's 17 my son's
15.
they've struggled a little bit because
they don't like zoom learning
and they can get down how's your son how
old is your son malcolm
my son will be 18 in april okay
yeah so how is he doing with all this he
does pretty well
he makes the kids in his class call him
king malcolm on
zoom he wears a burger king crown and
he just leans into it so it's delusions
of grandeur maybe yeah yeah if anything
he's like i call this i no longer want
to go to school so you all come to me
i wear a crown and i just do this online
but um you know he does miss some of his
friends and things but
he's been the real trooper that's
another person that makes me optimistic
when he's just like
uh it is what it is covert 19
sucks 2020 sucked but we just keep going
to school
right and i was like man like yeah
exactly yeah as long as he's got a
burger king crown
mm-hmm and he's excited for his birthday
he wrote his birthday list which is
every year wait a minute this is going
to be a big one so he's going to be 18.
so that 18 is a big year once you turn
18
certain doors open to like what you're
allowed to is he very aware of that oh
he is very well he's a rule follower i
think it's part of the autism that makes
him really just focus in on rules
but he's real aware he was like oh i
turn 18
r-rated movies he has a list he's like i
want explicit cds
the next thing said adult toys which i'm
[Laughter]
does he know does he know what he's not
does he know what adult toys are
i'm tired of these children toys i want
a dog toy
i truly hope he does not but you know
what it's time for him to learn
either way i did not know what an adult
toy was when i turned 18.
i did not i'm still not sure yeah that's
what your wife said
i wasn't sure i thought it was an egg
timer
she was like where did you find that it
was in your drawer
the eggs are i think ready